What's a good thing to do for nausea?
So nausea could be a problem. Why do cancer patients get nausea?
Google that one. You're gonna come up with a lot of answers for that.
The biggest reason why cancer patients get nausea is if they have any intestinal cancer. So any intestinal cancer can cause it back up of
of
bolus of food that could cause nausea.
Different brain cancers can cause nausea because the nausea center is in the midbrain. That's the deep part of the brain underneath the cerebral of the brain.
And
a person could have nausea due to just food consumption. Food makes them feel sick.
So there's multiple reasons why a person could have nausea with cancer.
What do you do with it? Because nausea can cause all sorts of upset. You just don't feel good. You feel like you got the flu all the time.
You feel like you don't, you know, eating doesn't make it better. Sometimes, does it make it worse? Sometimes I don't know what to eat.
It just, it gets very frustrating to bring a person down.
So I know a lot about nausea because this is one of my major symptoms right here is nausea.
So I get nausea all the time and I feel like I have the flu pretty much all the time.
So you don't help me.
We have two products that I think are really good. Personally, I have not used this. So I personally can't vouch for this though. I have some from patients have used this instead of thinking of what's great.
There's a product from herb barb. I use this. I guys all the time.
I am also used to district peppermint when I did them. I guys around. I guys has peppermint. It has a little ginger that I believe.
I also use cinnamon bark.
So cinnamon bark essential oil. I didn't put a picture of that out here works a little bit differently.
It's strong and stringent in your mouth. So it's a sharp oil. So it's a pretty hot oil.
And it's a cinnamon aldehyde is an aldehyde. So that's the that is the chemical component of cinnamon.
So the essential oil cinnamon bark has like I think 90% of the aldehydes is aldehydes are certain class of organic chemical.
I use cinnamon bark as part of my protocol. I usually take a drop or two. That's all I take two or three drops a day because I think aldehydes can be beneficial to help kill cancer.
But cinnamon also can help with me with some nausea. At home in the car, I usually carry a bottle of digest with me. If I get nausea, I take a drop.
But for me, nausea comes from the gut. But remember, it's a neurological function. So it's eliminated the nausea center of the brain. So for me, if I stay busy, so that's why I work 10 hours a day, 12 hours a day.
I stay busy. I keep my mind busy. I don't think about it. So I don't my mind is about it. And I don't think about it's usually what I relax. So it's time just to kind of chill out and relax. I had a busy day. I'm going to sit down.
That I start feeling worse. So I have a bottle of this city next to my chair at home that I usually sit at home.
So this is what he helped me. I can't really talk to much of this. I put the drops on your finger, though, because it can be kind of a hot oil. And then, and then put it in your mouth, on your tongue. This you can spray right in your mouth.
So I would not drop this this early in the month until you get used to the how much is coming in with the dropper. I'd start with putting it on your finger.
But that's helped me a lot. That's helped me with nausea. Also with the other help is make sure make sure make sure you're not constipated.
So if you're going to have nausea, so you have to make sure you're not constipated that you're having regular problems. If you're not, make sure you don't talk to me.